of our electrical grid and essential to
helping the pocketbooks of americans
around the country
they the executives and organizations
attending this discussion operate key
parts of america's power grid and they
know that the best way to ensure future
economic growth is to make long-term
investments to combat the climate crisis
increase the competitiveness of our
industries and protect our electrical
grid from extreme weather events armor
why don't you kick us off okay thanks
so new cpi numbers come out tomorrow and
e-commerce are forecasting uh uh index
of i believe seven point three percent
annually
now's why what you see in the data right
now that suggests inflation will fall
quickly this year and
how confident are you that a decrease in
inflation can occur without hurting
demand in the economy
well let me start with a little bit of a
preview just so well we don't know the
numbers i know there are projections but
just as people are preparing to look at
these numbers and prepare to report on
the numbers um
so first when we look at tomorrow's data
what we're looking at is uh recent
trends in inflation so in november and
december price increases showed rel
relative to the month before slowed
relatives of the month before and in
january they were down almost half
from where they were in october that's a
sign of progress that the inflationary
increases are increased decreasing i
should say month to month and we'll be
looking at that
wage growth compared
uh looking at wage growth compared to
inflation in january as well what is
also coming out tomorrow is annual data
right which is i think what you're
talking about uh and so as we're looking
at that uh we do
we expect a high year-over-year
inflation rate reading in tomorrow's
data given what we know about the last
year right and what we've seen over the
last year uh that's because
year-over-year data largely reflects the
price increases over the last year as
we've already talked about and we know
about uh it's not about the most recent
trends which i think is the important
component for people to look at right
there's monthly and then there's also
the annual data so above seven percent
as i think some are predicting would not
be a surprise even though we don't know
what the data is going to be going to be
but looking at that reading of it as we
prepare for tomorrow is still consistent
with the path in our view to go to your
question
that leading out outside forecasters
continue to project that inflation
inflation is expected to decrease over
the course and moderate over the course
of this year so that continues to be
outside projections even as we're
preparing for the new data tomorrow i
think there was another part of your
question but i wanted to explain what
people should prepare for well i guess
with
the
just getting back to how confident are
you that a decrease can occur
uh without hurting uh demand in the
economy
well i would say as you know the federal
reserve has purview over um uh over uh
taking the independent approaches that
they should choose to and we certainly
as the president has said he welcomes
and and supports their uh efforts to
take steps or their plans to take steps
uh in terms of our confidence we again
rely on what their projections are about
the the uh the projection that inflation
will come down that it will moderate uh
and we are also continuing to
take steps to continue to grow the
economy continue to address the needs
that the american people have in the
economy
i can ask a question about
new york today with the latest
to work on their mass
mandate several states for now it seems
well ahead of the federal government and
explain the path out of the pandemic
is the president now falling behind
states and explaining to americans how
or we all can sort of resume our normal
lives
well the president has been clear and
has said that we are moving toward a
time when cobit won't disrupt our daily
lives a time when kobit won't be a
constant crisis i think you all heard
him talk about that in his press
conference two weeks ago uh and that is
something that as jeff zions i believe
just said during the covid briefing
earlier today there's an active and
ongoing uh work plan uh to develop a
path forward and that is uh there's
constant discussion about that i think
what you're referring to as it relates
to new york which is an important
component especially as americans are
consuming what it means and where we're
going of masks and what the mass
guidance is dr wolinski was also on this
coveted briefing that happened just
earlier this morning and what she
conveyed on that briefing i know there's
a lot going on she may not have all seen
what she said but is that we certainly
understand the need to be flexible we
want to ensure that public health
guidance we're providing meets the
moment we're in we recognize people are
tired of the pandemic they're tired of
wearing masks i bet all of you are i
certainly know i am
we all understand that but that what our
focus is on is looking at uh the data
and the science so there's good there
are positive signs as she referred to
cases and hospitalizations are falling
we're looking at all of the guidance
based on the latest data and science she
also said which is i think important for
people to note that
we continue to while we continue to
recommend masking in areas of high and
substantial transmission which is
basically the entire country at this
point that's essentially everywhere for
indoor settings we are evaluating uh
rates of transmission uh we're
evaluating and looking at data to see if
any changes need to be made and that is
something of course the cdc continues to
do so i would say that we are internally
discussing of course um what it looks
like to be in the phase of the fight
against the coveted pandemic where it is
not disrupting everyone's daily lives
where people are moving on and living um
you know lives free of hopefully masks
at some point and um
many of the restrictions that we've all
been living through over the past two
years but as a the federal government we
have the responsibility to rely on data
on science on the medical experts that's
something the president committed to
during the campaign they committed they
confirmed during this briefing they are
continuing to evaluate and there's
ongoing discussions and work happening
thing internally pentagon has yet to
commit to immediate embeds with u.s
troops
that i have and are deploying uh the
baltics
why and um
is this consistent just generally with
the administration's pledge to
transparency
well i just saw the reports about this
and i will acknowledge too i have to dig
into this a little bit further i
certainly understand the question and
the desire uh to be embedded with troops
and seeing what's happening on the
ground just as many of you have uh
reporters and outlets who are near the
border or seeing what's happening for
yourselves the military buildup of
troops so let me check into this and see
if i can get back to all of you go ahead
john following up on that does the white
house generally support the notion of
troops and betting with u.s troops
around the world
we certainly have in the past yes
but i know that the trump administration
took a different view so
does this white house envision a return
to the practice of u.s journalists and
betting with u.s forces when they're in
eastern europe for example
uh in in the nation's interest that has
been our overarching approach as you've
seen over the last year i'd have to
check into this specific question that
umer has asked man and i think you're
following up on okay great um the white
house has made it pretty clear there is
no plan for a mass evacuation of
american citizens in ukraine um and in
fact you and president and others have
suggested that americans who are in
ukraine should leave now if they can
at the same time it's been projected
that russia could overtake heaves in two
days if it invades so
what happens to americans if they do get
stranded in ukraine should they
understand that the us is not coming to
get them
well
let's just take a step back here first
we don't know that president putin has
made a decision to invade we still don't
have a new assessment on that right i'm
obviously not going to discuss
intelligence reports which i think you
also referenced uh what i can tell you
is that it's not just that the president
or i have been
conveying this warning to u.s citizens
this is something the state department
has been doing for weeks and weeks and
weeks now i know there have also been a
range of reports out there about
american citizens as you all know
because we've discussed this before u.s
citizens are not required to register
their travel to a foreign country with
us and we don't maintain a comprehensive
list of u.s citizens that said the state
department does estimate does estimates
from time to time and i know there have
been much larger numbers out there so i
just wanted to uh reiterate for all of
you that back in october the state
department estimated there were at the
time so months ago about 6 600 u.s
citizens residing in ukraine not much
far much not much larger than that there
have been of course there are periodic
times during the holiday season where
there are assessments of tourists and
visitors and
others but in terms of
citizens residing in ukraine many of
which would be
dual citizens so what people should
understand is that the united states
does not typically do mass evacuations
of course the situation in afghanistan
was unique for many reasons including
that it was the end of a 20-year war we
were bringing a war to an end we were
not trying to prevent a war as we are
certainly in this case there are a range
of means that individuals and americans
can depart from ukraine and we've been
encouraging them to do exactly that but
what we have been how we've been looking
at this is much more much more similar
to uh what was ordered in ethiopia or
kazakhstan
in recent months where this the security
circumstances on the ground warranted uh
travel advisories and warnings from the
state department and can you explain how
the process would work if the u.s
citizens were able to make it by land to
poland or romania what's the plan that's
being put in place to help them you mean
if they cross the border well there are
if there is an invasion well there are
still i think what we're encouraging
american citizens to do is depart now
obviously there hasn't been an invasion
uh and we don't know that there uh has
been a decision to invade uh obviously
we have a range of diplomatic uh
presences uh not only in ukraine but in
neighboring countries that are always
available for us citizens should they
need assistance good thanks jen um hhs
just put out a statement clarifying um
around some of the reports
that crack pipes or not would be part of
the safe smoking kits that are funded by
the administration
but can you clarify for us
were they never a part of the kit or
were they removed in response to this
reporting and this push back
they were never a part of the kit it was
inaccurate reporting and we wanted to
put out information to make that clear
what is in the same smoking kit
uh some safe smoking skin may contain
alcohol swabs lip balm other materials
to promote hygiene and reduce the
transmission of diseases like hiv and
hepatitis i would note that what we're
really talking about here is steps that
we're taking as a federal government to
address the opioid epidemic which is
killing
tens of thousands if not more americans
every single day week month of the year
we put out this statement though because
there was inaccurate information out
there i should say hhs put out the
statement because there was inaccurate
information out there and we wanted to
provide clarification on the allowable
uses for the hhs harm reduction program
it's not a change in policy this program
though is focused on harm reduction
strategies including prioritizing the
use of fentanyl test strips and clean
syringes and all of these harm reduction
services uh that will be supported by
these programs are intended to save
lives from an epidemic that we know is
uh is devastating to communities across
the country
and then so just for a final point on it
does the administration support any
effort then to distribute drug
paraphernalia
we the statement makes clear that we
don't support federal funding indirect
or direct for pipes
and then on the safe injection sites
that the doj is evaluating
was this a an ask from the white house
that they review that policy to know
that for years doj has opposed efforts
to open safe injection sites it's under
litigation so i can't speak to that but
what i can tell you and reiterate is
that
the white house is committed as i will
as i would reiterate for you many
democrats and republicans including
senator cruz uh to taking steps to
address the opioid crisis this is not an
issue that is inflicting just blue
states it is inflicting millions of
americans across the country and it is
important that we take steps to address
it
just final wrap of those two items what
would you say to
critics who are concerned that
the administration
is
somehow encouraging illegal drug use
i think that it's important to step back
and remember just to put a little more
of a fine point on it that we're losing
an american life every five minutes to
overdose we don't have time for
political games
the president's focused on saving lives
through harm reduction programs that's
exactly what we're talking about here
they work in red states and they work in
blue states we know they save lives they
help connect people to treatment and
recovery and they were endorsed this
week by a bipartisan commission
co-chaired by senator tom cotton that
examine steps we must take to address
the devastating toll of overdoses so
what i would say is this is not a game
this is not a political game this is an
epidemic that is taking the life of a
five of uh of an american every five
minutes and we need to work in a
bipartisan way to address it can i ask
about masks um we had
another state today uh dropping the
indoor mass mandate as the cdc is
confirming that their guidance is not
changing
but these decisions that are being made
at the local level like you guys always
talk about are out of step with the
science that is at the forefront
of the cdc of this white house so
why are we not hearing the same
messaging criticizing states that are
you know making these moves like we
heard previously
with
for instance rhonda sanders
well i would say there is a distinct
difference between standing in the way
which ron desantis did our governor
desantis i'll give him his full title
of teachers school administrators and
others taking steps to protect the
students in their school communities
there's a difference between standing in
the way of it threatening to pull back
funding and allowing for local school
districts to make choices which is what
a number of these states are doing
go ahead
quick follow-up on that does the
administration risk looking out of touch
with where the country is heading in
terms of lifting these mass mandates if
the cdc doesn't revise its violence well
again
we understand where the emotions of the
country are right people are uh
tired of masks i would say not even if
you look at the polling though there is
also a huge chunk of people who still
want masks right so it's not even that
specific it's just that as you noted
there are some states that are moving
towards rolling back or giving more
choice to local communities about how
they will implement these requirements
but again from the federal government uh
what our responsibility to do is to
abide by what the president committed to
on the campaign which is to listen to
scientists listen to data
that doesn't move at the state of
politics it moves at the speed of data
and they uh dr walensky committed to
convey or extra take confirmed that they
were evaluating this at the cdc and i
want to just ask you about russia um you
were very careful in your wording when
you were asked yesterday the extent to
which the administration
um
understands what happened between
presidents mcronan president putin
can you give us any more information
today
to what extent has
the administration been briefed has the
president been briefed directly before
the spokesman president this morning
which i believe we confirmed yes and
what does he understand about what came
out of that meeting does he have the
same sense of optimism that president
macron had when he left that meeting
that yes perhaps there had been a tiny
bit of progress in terms of helping uh
create an offering for president
well kristin uh the president spoke as i
noted with president macron earlier
today um he as you know spoke hosted the
german chancellor and i expect he will
speak with a number of other european
counterparts
as the week proceeds but what we're
looking at here kristin is
not reports out of a meeting but whether
or not russia is taking de-escalatory
steps they are not they are taking
escalatory not de-escalatory steps we
certainly hope that that changes so you
based on the intelligence that you have
do not share the same
measured optimism that president putin
have coming out of that again we're
looking at uh we're looking at actions
here and we have not seen de-esculatory
actions by the russians any imminent
plans for
president biden to speak with president
as you probably are tired of having to
say but i'll just repeat it uh the
president certainly values a leader to
leader engagement um he has spoken with
president putin as you know uh multiple
times in the past including in person uh
but i don't have anything to preview at
this point in time if i could just ask
you one question overnight
the president tweeted about this
potential bill that has been proposed in
florida that would restrict school
districts from
encouraging discussion about sexual
orientation or gender identity in public
schools the president tweeted out that
he wanted them to know that you are
loved and accepted just as you are i
have your back what if anything
can president biden do is he planning to
do if in fact that does pass
well i would say unfortunately
this is not the only bill or the only
effort we're seeing across the country
to
to really
regulate what students can or cannot
read what they can or cannot learn and
most troubling who they can or cannot be
as i think you saw in the president's
treat tweet
it's cruel it's harmful um
and uh you know it is certainly
something that is not helping
you know young people who are members of
the lgbtqi plus community who are
already vulnerable already being bullied
i think the president felt it was
important to speak out um but in terms
of specific actions uh you know we're
going to continue to voice our strong
views on this it's significant the
president did that and if there's any
additional steps i'll i'll let you know
go ahead thanks jen uh back to ukraine
for a second uh tomorrow it's expected
to be these uh this russia belarus
military exercise um is it the sense of
this administration
that what's expected to be this massive
show of force tomorrow and for the next
few days after that could provide some
sort of cover
for an invasion and
is the white house and our its allies on
any kind of heightened alert given
what's expected to happen
i wouldn't make a prediction of that i'm
sure your colleagues will ask the
pentagon that question but i think as we
look at the preparation for these
military exercises again we see this as
certainly more of an escalatory not a
de-escalatory action uh as it relates to
those troops and the military exercises
this is happening at the border of
uh at the border as well uh so uh that
is certainly concerning to us but i
wouldn't make a prediction of what it
means in terms of invasion
back to mass not to belabor it but um
in in a matter of weeks americans have
heard the white house say masks are so
important you should get online and
order yours for your family right now uh
you've got now this wave of states that
are saying actually you don't have to
necessarily wear masks we're going to do
away with some of these mandates and now
you've got the cdc saying it's guiding
the stance we're going to review things
about the guides and stamps
can you blame americans for being
confused and frustrated and having no
idea who they should be listening to
right now well our guidance is
consistently has consistently been this
uh
when you are in a high transmission area
which is everywhere in the country you
should wear a mask in indoor settings
including schools uh there are states uh
that have uh rolled back their mass
guidelines that have given more
flexibility to communities
they're different it's not uniform
whatever state has done uh and certainly
we continue to advise and recommend
abiding by public health guidelines
americans are confused by what's
happening well i think we should do
everything we can to prevent them from
being confused so i'm restating what our
policy is here from the federal
government which is based on public
health guidelines does the cdc run the
risk of becoming irrelevant in the minds
of many americans given that their
states are moving along ahead without
them well i don't think the the
federal experts on health and medical
advice should be irrelevant to americans
at a time where we're still facing a
pandemic go ahead uh negotiations on the
russian sanction bill have stalled in in
congress or hit a bump
um what is the the latest white house
thinking on that bill what are some of
the things you want to see emerge
in the weeks ahead or days ahead sure
well first we believe it's an important
important to show a united front to
russia and hence uh we've been doing a
range of uh briefings with democratic
and republican leadership uh and members
and committees over the course of the
last several weeks we've been gratified
by the bipolar partisan support we've
seen for the actions we've taken
and we'll take if russia further invades
ukraine we welcome the bipartisan focus
on russia and ukraine and congress and
think that a bipartisan bill would send
a strong message to president putin
there's momentum building for a bill to
bar alarm lawmakers from owning stock
does the white house believe that
lawmakers should
should own stock
well
let me just first reiterate something
many of you covered the campaign mayor
to be familiar with but uh one president
biden believes has never
been somebody who's owned and traded
stock as a member of the senate uh he's
talked about that a lot throughout his
career uh during the campaign he
committed to work with congress to take
steps uh to
to
ensure that there wasn't conflicts of
interest that are being presented as
as as this legislation is being
discussed and he also believes that all
government agencies and officials
including independent agencies should be
held to the highest ethical standards
it's early in the legislative process
so i don't have a new comment uh today
on the specifics of this legislation but
i would just reiterate how the president
has operated and conducted himself as he
has been in public life for uh just a
few years now
uh last question senator manchin has
talked about there's no more build back
better bill publicly has the white house
or your team ever considered
rebranding the bill a name change is
that something that you've considered
and you think would be beneficial sure
look i think our objective is uh is
working with uh democrats republicans if
they decide they're for lowering the
cost of prescription drugs they're
welcome to join us in this effort um but
to determine how much of the president's
buildback better agenda whatever you
call it can be moved forward and there
is agreement on a number of big
components including with senator
manchin about the importance of lowering
the cost of child care what burden in
that has on families across the country
about the importance of lowering the
cost of health care of making the tax
system more fair of negotiating of
allowing medicare to negotiate the price
of prescription drugs something the
president will be going to virginia
tomorrow to talk about so uh these
discussions are ongoing a lot of them as
the pr you heard the president say at
the press conference two weeks ago are
happening between members on the hill
right to determine what they can have
support for uh and our our staff and
senior members of the team are engaged
in those as well
go ahead
jen given that the cdc guideline still
remains that masking is recommended in
schools if you are a parent a teacher or
student living in a state where that is
no longer recommended should you still
follow the cdc guideline yes
so even if the state is not requiring
that you wear masks in the schools well
this is where we would advise any
american to follow the cdc guidelines
and as dr wolinski said and you and you
referenced uh they're they're constantly
evaluating right because uh the data's
changing the science is cheating
changing it certainly is as positive uh
that case numbers have come down
hospitalizations come down and they look
at all of that information that's why
it's also important to note the
difference between leaders who are
saying we're going to leave it up to
localities local school school districts
to make decisions
no parent who wants to send their kid
with a mask should be penalized no
teacher or who wants to wear a mask
should be penalized or school district
who makes that choice should be
penalized uh but it a lot of these
decisions have been up to local school
districts in the past we have
made uh we have funded and we have and
we have made announcements about a
number of mitigation measures which we
will continue to work with school
districts to implement
and it's been
almost a month i think since president
biden addressed the issue of the
pandemic in the form of major speech why
has it been that long since americans
have heard from him in sort of that kind
of a setting about the pandemic
well i i would say first the president
answered questions about the pandemic
less than two weeks ago during a press
conference and
certainly we have regular coveted
briefings to provide the american people
with an update on where things stand
we're currently as i noted a little bit
earlier discussing what the next phase
of the pandemic looks like that's an
ongoing process and the american people
can expect to continue to hear from the
president on it would it be fair to say
that the president believes the country
is turning a corner on the pandemic
again i don't want to characterize other
than to convey that
we look at hospitalization numbers
they're coming down that's a good sign
there's no question about that uh we are
looking at all of the tools we have in
our toolbox uh which is certainly puts
us in a very different position than we
were in a year ago whether it's the
anti-viral pills the ability to send out
masks and tests to americans who want
them the fact that 75 percent of adults
are vaccinated this is all good these
are all good signs all good information
uh but we're continuing to discuss and
assess internally what what the next
phase might look like and i'd like to
ask you a question about a cnn
investigation about the kabul airport
blast back in august
this investigation looked at medical
records it interviewed doctors in kabul
victims and witnesses and it raises some
questions about whether anyone was hit
by gunfire either by u.s or british
troops after the airport bomb blast so
we're wondering should the pentagon
further investigate this matter or does
the president believe that this matter
is closed well i know that my colleague
john kirby is going to brief later this
afternoon and centcom has put out
information on this but i would really
point you to them for their comment
god thank you jeff um i have a question
about how the president
is going to make the decision
about
uh changing the recommendation on mass
is it is he totally he will make the
decision based on what the cdc advises
yeah okay so the cdc calls the shots
here it's not like he measures
trade-offs the economy mental health
people's behavior it's just when the cdc
says it's okay to do
that's what will determine his decision
but he doesn't take into account all
these other factors well what uh he has
made made the commitment to the american
people on uh back when he ran for
president and we've tried to abide by is
that he would listen to
listen to the data listen to the science
uh and certainly our health and medical
team obviously the cdc is part of that
dr fauci other experts you've heard
though i would note uh dr murthy and
others talk about mental health impacts
um so i would point you to them to talk
about all the factors but we're
certainly going to listen to our doctors
and medical experts
what does listen mean does it mean that
the cdc
calls the shots here or as these
governors have done
does the president take into account the
trade-offs i mean this is about public
health it's not like just some kind of
abstract thing in a vacuum people a
kid's mental health is affected by
wearing masks human behavior is part of
this the economy is part of this does he
take those into account or does he
assume the cdc will do that for him well
i think mara it's also important to note
that masks are effective at reducing
transmission in schools and other places
and we know that uh from what the data
has told us right uh there are a range
of health and medical experts who advise
the president and make determinations
about how the cdc guidance will be
changed but that is what we rely on yes
a lot of doctors are now signing
statements saying it's time to lift math
mandates especially for kids
i understand that but we rely on the
health and medical experts who work on
the federal government as as we should
even as we account for and consult with
outside experts go ahead mr you
mentioned the president's trip tomorrow
virginia um
do you expect a new announcement of some
sort on prescription drug prices or is
it going to be kind of a familiar
argument about the importance of
his buildback better plan and
he'll be apparent alongside a vulnerable
house democrat
well that type of
travel where he'll be
going out but the democrats facing tough
re-election battles he's sort of the
north star as he
uh
accelerates his travel schedule or at
least has said that he wants to do it
sure well on your second question you
know i've become quite careful about
what i say about politics and
campaigning from this podium but the
president himself has said uh so i can
point to that uh that he is eager to uh
go out there and uh and hit the road for
democrats who are fighting for uh an an
agenda for the american people so uh
certainly tomorrow when he is out uh in
uh the richmond area with congresswoman
uh um
spanberger um this is an opportunity for
him to go back to your first question to
really talk about um his view that the
fact that americans are forced to pay
two to three times more for drugs and
citizens and other advanced economies is
unacceptable it's flat out wrong and we
need to act to stop the abuse of
american families
he as you've heard him say many times
and i expect you would hear him say
tomorrow insulin which was invented over
100 years ago cost roughly ten dollars
to make but families are sometimes
charged over a thousand dollars for that
for it that's unacceptable uh it causes
untold pain for thousands and thousands
of families and medicare being able to
negotiate the cost of prescription drugs
i don't know that it needs to be a new
policy it's a good policy supported by
many many americans the vast majority
across the country democrats and
republicans independents and uh we
obviously want to continue to fight to
get it done
um iran announced today that they
had or said that they've developed a
missile uh that construct israel or uf
bases in the region um i'm wondering if
you have a reaction to that and then
also kind of generally want to check in
on
where you thought the product the sort
of progress on uh talks over a new
nuclear deal or are standing right now
well in terms of where things stand um a
special envoy mali uh in his interagency
delegation um have been in vienna for
the eighth round of talks um as we've
said and this is a consistent the report
you reference consistent with this iran
our talks with iran have reached an
urgent point on mutual return to full
implantation of the jcpoa a deal that
addresses the core concerns of all sides
is in sight but if it is not reached in
the in the coming weeks iran's ongoing
nuclear advances will make it impossible
for us to return to the jcpoa
so those talks and conversations are
going ongoing
but i would say that as we noted back i
believe in december the president asked
his team to prepare a range of
contingencies because we are at a
pivotal point because of the progress
that they have made in recent years as a
result of the former president and his
team pulling out of the nuclear deal
go ahead yeah thank you um does the
president have a particular opinion
about this trucker action going on in
canada
right now because it does it is
affecting otherwise obviously for these
war crossings
and
could it have possibly have some impact
on the u.s economy yeah
it's continuous so we're we are watching
this very closely um and um
uh because as you kind of touched on
here the ambassador bridge is canada's
busiest link to the united states and
accounts for about 25 of trade between
the two countries and so the blockade
poses a risk to supply chains for the
auto industry because the bridge is a
key conduit for motor vehicles
components and parts and delays uh risk
disrupting auto production we are in
close contact we've been doing a great
deal of work on this lisherwood randall
our homeland security advisor convened a
meeting just today we're in very close
contact and coordination with the custom
and border protection team and canadian
counterparts michigan governor whitmer
and industry stakeholders uh we are also
monitoring very closely and engaged with
auto companies on what the impacts could
be of auto parts which is what would
come from canada uh and the impact on
the united states we're also looking
tracking potential disruptions to u.s
agricultural exports from michigan into
canada there are a number of steps that
we have proactively taken i should say
because the customs and border
protection team uh they've worked with
canadian counterparts to route traffic
from ambassador bridge to blue water
bridge there's still a lengthy delay but
it is enabling some of these trucks and
transports to
get through
they also opened all nine commercial
lanes including a fast lane at the port
to process diverted traffic and they're
working closely with relevant automakers
and other public and private sector
stakeholders to discuss alternative
processing so we're working to ensure
there's movement the other issue let me
just touch on what you didn't ask about
but it's an important component too is
there are workers who need to go across
the bridge um to get to canada or to get
to the united states um and the two we
are the workers uh they go over the
ambassador bridge typically they are
being um detoured to the detroit windsor
tunnel which is open and which enabling
them to move move past so we're very
focused on this the president is focused
on this um and we are working very
closely with
the team at dhs with canadian officials
and others to do everything we can to
alleviate the impact
the president have an opinion on this uh
action
an opinion on it and
what tell me more what you're doing
about the message they want to send well
we support peaceful protest
but we have concerns when those protests
turn violent and certainly i think it's
important for everyone in canada and the
united states to understand what the
impact of this blockage is a potential
impact on uh on workers on the supply
chain and that is where we are most
focused
go ahead i'll come back to you again
thank you jen a couple questions on
schools and guidelines around covent
you're saying you know the cdc uh its
guidance remains that there be universal
messaging schools and the white house
supports that recommendation
as you point out some of these
democratic governors who are lifting
mass mandates in schools they are
allowing local authorities to make some
decisions but the reality is there are
going to be a lot of parents who no
longer have their children or masks
in schools and given community
transmission is still high across the
country i mean the whole map on the cdc
website is red are you not concerned
that these decisions
are going to potentially lead to
outbreaks in schools well uh our focus
continues to be to recommend everyone
follow cdc guidance right and we know
that uh wearing masks effectively
reduces transmission as much as people
are understandably tired of wearing
masks we understand that there were a
number of other mitigation measures that
schools have taken obviously now kids
age 5 to 11 are eligible to get to be
vaccinated
testing so kids can remain in the
classroom even if there's a case is
something we have also talked about and
supported and funding from the american
rescue plan ensured that there was
capacity and ability to improve
ventilation social distancing and take
other steps that are also effective
mitigation measures uh in schools uh but
again uh you know our view is that if a
student or a parent chooses to wear a
mask they should be able to freely so
that and they should not be prevented
from doing that
you know one this is happening as we
still see this trend where there is a
drop-off in the vaccination rate when
you
reach
those who are under 18 among adolescents
i think it's just over half of
adolescents are vaccinated an even
bigger drop off among those who are aged
5 to 11 with pretty high numbers still
around vaccine hesitancy
why hasn't the
white house called for a vaccine
requirement against copenhagen for k-12
schools which many public health experts
say is really the only way that you will
be able to protect students in the long
term because those decisions have
historically been up to school districts
good
all right a couple questions um on the
child tax credit mitt romney has
suggested that you consider the
bipartisan path toward his alternative
version of the program does he have ten
republicans
he says that he has a bipartisan group
that's been successful in the past and
that he's gonna try and get here has the
white house engaged with him on this
recently we've been engaged with every
member who is open to engaging and
looking uh to move the president's
agenda forward is his version
unacceptable
to the white house i don't have any
specific reaction to his version but i
would just note that in order to get any
component of the president's agenda
forward if it's broken off of a
reconciliation package you'd need 60
votes
on the coven uh kristen ortiza who spoke
to the nominating convention for the
president told us a couple weeks ago
that she's disappointed that the
president hasn't met and engaged more
directly with people who are affected by
coping
over 900 000 deaths now are there any
plans for the president to host people
of the white house who have been
affected by covetous families
i'm happy to check and see if there's
any plans i would note that the
president um
has spoken
about kovid and his
plans and his commitment to addressing
the
pandemic more than perhaps any other
issue since he became president and more
importantly that than that's i think
most americans he's taken very specific
actions to ensure that vaccines are
available that tests are available that
masks are available that schools are
open which that is what impacts people's
lives on a daily basis but i can see if
there's any plans for that go ahead
um is it the sense inside the white
house that the decisions by democratic
governors to relax some of these mass
guidelines is driven
mostly by as you said the state of
politics and not the public health
guidelines that are driving the federal
government's policy i didn't actually
make that assessment but i would point
you to all of them to ask them questions
about what they base their decision
making on but
again we understand local leaders we
continue to to advise local leaders
whether they're governors or others to
make decisions based on the science and
data about what's happening in their
communities
and what is going to keep kids in school
safe what is going to keep kids and
their people and their communities safe
and we will continue to abide by what
federal guidance uh is advising which is
based on the
the
science and health experts in the
federal government and then on the
meeting later today with president biden
and the companies how much is
he relying on these companies to make uh
clean energy decisions kind of on their
own in the absence of
climate legislation that is you know
currently stalled or being renegotiated
in congress right now that we know would
be necessary to reach the white house's
goals on clean energy well i think as as
many of these leaders have said i mean
they know that the industry of the
future is clean energy and so there is
an incentive for them to act and move in
that direction
and certainly the president agrees with
that and there are a number of steps
even as we're working to continue to
push to get built back better passed
that we have already passed into law as
a part of the infrastructure bill for
example uh including
clean charging us
charging stations around the country
incentivizing the purchase of electric
vehicles which of course is a is an
industry that will help uh many of the
american auto industry
producers uh prosper over the course of
time uh but certainly it's it's where
the industry is going uh and there's
agreement between government and many of
these industries about the opportunity
for the united states to be a leader in
the clean energy movement in the world
go ahead thank you so much uh i just
have two foreign questions in iran
follow-up starting with build back
better world do we have any news on when
that's going to be officially launched
have you identified any programs
can you share any details well we've
talked the president's talked about this
quite a lot on the global stage let me
see if we can get an update from the nsc
team about any new specifics on it
something that president
putin said sure the other day
he made what many russian speakers
interpreted as a rape joke directed at
ukraine
given the diplomacy is all about talking
how does the administration view talk
like this does it shorten the diplomatic
off-ramp because it's a pretty
undiplomatic thing to say and has the
white house communicated to the kremlin
you know
yo that's not cool
well first i would say that um any joke
about rape would certainly be something
that everyone in this government would
be outraged by whether it's happening
from the mouth of a u.s official or a
foreign official i'd also note that we
have never held back in our concern
about the
lack of truthfulness of some of the
statements that come out of the mouth of
president putin and members of the
russian
leadership
and also the bellicose rhetoric that has
come out of their mouths so uh we have
never held back on our concern uh and
certainly uh that joke would not be
something that we
i don't have anything more in terms of
diplomatic discussions go ahead bro um
jen two topics on one
back on the hhs issue yeah and pipes
you know misinformation has a terrible
ripple effect
what is this administration doing
because this has
permeated a lot of corridors that um
people are taking this in are you or the
administration or hhs planning on doing
something
beyond the statement to let people know
that this is misinformation
yeah
that's a really important point because
i think there's been a lot of
misinformation about particularly this
issue and
and it has really clouded over what is a
hugely important issue in this country
which is a fight against the opioid
epidemic and the need to have a
bipartisan
approaches that are going to help
communities that are impacted address it
but yes we will certainly be building
out our efforts to effectively
communicate
that
we are not
that what is in a safe smoking kit what
is not in a smoking safe smoking kit and
what we are effectively trying to do
with our harm reduction program
damage has a lot of damage already been
done just by this information
in certain communities are you finding
we certainly have seen it and i think
april one of the reasons we felt even
though we have never this has never been
a part of what has been funded we felt
it was important to put out a public
statement from uh from the federal
government to make that clear because we
saw the spreading of misinformation and
the fact that it was having an impact on
a range of communities and we felt even
though it was never true that we needed
to put out a proactive statement
okay and and uh second topic i asked you
on monday yeah about uh president biden
and his last the last time he talked to
anita hill do you have any more you did
ask me that i don't have an update on
that i will venture to see if i can get
one today is she part of the external
group
that is working with the white house on
these nominations for supreme court
there are a broad range of individuals
legal experts scholars members of
congress of both parties that are being
consulted with we have not put out that
list of individuals publicly i can see
if there's more information we can
provide
glenn middleton thanks jen two quick
questions one
we've heard from the white house about
this effort to reach out to republican
senators on supreme court yeah
nomination i wondered uh if you could
explain a little bit kind of what the
focus of those conversations are are you
guys you know
fielding suggestions on who the nominee
should be are you giving them a short
list and getting their reaction i'm just
kind of curious sort of what the focus
of the outreach to republicans is well
um
as the president has said and we just
reiterate we we're going to choose a
nominee he's going to choose a nominee
whose qualifications record character
and devotion to the constitution and
rule of law make them deserving of
support on from both sides of the aisle
and there are many candidates at the top
of their field who fit that profile and
who have received bipartisan support in
the past so these conversations are not
uniform right sometimes and the
president is certainly seeking input
seeking feedback but he is treating the
process as he as he believes it should
be treated which is with seriousness
which is approaching it from uh from a
bipartisan manner and seeking
engagement and advice uh from a range of
officials elected and non-elected and
secondly unrelated but um there was some
reporting this week that labor secretary
marty walsh has offered to help resolve
major league baseball lockout and i
wonder uh if the president has been in
touch with him about that or if he has
an opinion or a viewpoint on the lockout
i'm happy to check on that and my
husband is also looking for an answer so
i will i will check on that i don't have
anything new go ahead yeah
yesterday in the event you highlighted
electric electric vehicles yeah today
you're highlighting the utility
companies out here three percent of the
market uh is electric and for vehicles
in the u.s so if americans go out and
buy a lot of electric cars can the grid
handle the load uh without using more
coal power
well i think we're trying to address
this from many fronts right as you know
and you've seen in the president's
infrastructure legislation uh which
includes additional charging stations
which includes incentivizing and making
it more affordable and accessible for
americans to purchase electric vehicles
but what we're seeing is the increase in
the market for electric vehicles
increase year by year right as they
become more affordable as there are more
charging stations as they are able to
as more americans can see themselves
driving electric vehicles and this is
certainly something not just the federal
government but many of these automobile
industries
companies are also seeing opportunity
end so uh we're all moving to uh as the
increase of the as the market is
increasing uh as more americans are
purchasing these electric vehicles to
ensure there are the charging stations
and the mechanisms needed for them to be
driven wind and solar handle that amount
of load on the system well again we're
working to uh to increase all of the um
all of the components of what is needed
to ensure that electric vehicles can be
powered across the country
when the president met with governors
last week did any of them ask
specifically for more guidance from the
federal government as they were
considering easing some of the covet
restrictions and did any express any
frustration that the cdc is not moving
quickly enough for them i'm not going to
speak for the governors they can
certainly speak for themselves um i can
just speak for what our position is what
we've conveyed to the governors which is
exactly what i've outlined for all of
you have the president urged any
governors to hold off on easing these
restrictions has he had any direct
conversations since then about what
they've all started announcing this week
we are continuing to convey directly to
governors our recommendation that they
abide by federal public health
guidelines but also our understanding
and uh that uh that they may make
decisions based on what they feel is
best for their uh communities he had
conversations i don't have any to write
out for you
go ahead
hello so president biden nominated um
los angeles mayor eric garcetti to the
u.s ambassador to india
garcetti's former top spokeswoman has
filed a complaint
with state local and federal prosecutors
demanding that he be prosecuted for
perjury for repeatedly denying
that he knew about another former aids
alleged sexual misconduct uh she's
saying that the mayor lied under oath
during his testimony before a u.s senate
committee considering his appointment to
the ambassadorship is the president
aware of this complaint has he spoken to
the mayor does he plan to rescind
garcetti's nomination
there's no plans to rescind any
nominations um i would point you to
mayor garcetti's office for any further
comment
go ahead
thank you um about the um
virus again um is the reluctance of the
president now i mean it seems to be at
least cautioned put it that way
the approach he's taken compared to a
lot of the others um
is there any link between that and
perhaps having felt planned
during the summer when we had this
independence from the virus are you
referring to that sorry yeah okay
referring to the mass and
his caution kind of moving on
as as obviously a quite a number of
people are doing uh is this in any way
linked to him feeling a little burned by
what happened during the summer when you
know the delta became pretty much as he
was
fighting people for a barbecue here to
celebrate independence he is basing his
decision or on what the advice of our
health and medical experts continues to
be and the fact that they are continuing
to evaluate and look at the data and the
science and that is a commitment he made
to the american people at the beginning
we also recognize that while
hospitalization rates are coming down
there's still high transmission rates
throughout basically the entire country
and he is cognizant of that as well
and the fact that we need to look at the
totality of that
and make recommendations based on what
our science experts are conveying
okay what an old stream if i might quit
sure um he said it's very clearly he
promises literally promises to stop it
stop north stream uh if there's an
invasion like a like a full-blown
invasion
if there isn't a full-blown invasion
which obviously is at least as likely as
there being one and it could be you know
100 different things that could be
happening over the next month year two
years
not to mention that russia already
occupies part of ukraine and so on
what what's the rationale for supporting
north stream at all we don't support
nordstrom we have been clear we oppose
the nordstrom 2 pipeline which is a
russian geopolitical project that
undercuts the energy security and
national security of a significant part
of the euro atlantic community that's
long been our position it's not online
the pipeline uh the german regulars have
said it is not currently on track to be
approved until at least the latter half
of 2022 and will continue to work with
germany ukraine and other allies and
partners to implement
the july 21st joint statement and again
if russia invades ukraine
nordstrom 2 will not come online
if you have any comment on a series of
bomb threats that are happening in dc
schools right now d.c police are
reporting that dunbar theodore roosevelt
ron brown high school several others are
now um under bomb threat and evacuating
schools
what do you say about that especially
after yesterday i don't have any new
information on these threats i'm happy
to see if there's a new updated comment
we can get for all of you of course we
are in touch with local school districts
as we have been since yesterday and our
uh and our homeland security experts uh
we'll do everything we can to ensure uh
that schools have the resources they
need but i don't have any new
information on it
you everyone